[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about the top 10 overpowered
characters in the world of the seven
deadly sins make sure you like and
subscribe for more seven deadly sins
videos for daily seven deadly sins posts
and conversations be sure to follow us
on instagram at anime uproar just so you
know there will most definitely be manga
spoilers in this video and you'll notice
that I used the word overpowered rather
than strongest I'm not simply going to
be looking at the strongest characters
currently in the manga in that case
Eskin or wouldn't even make the cut
since he doesn't have the power sunshine
anymore and that wouldn't be right since
we all know that Lord s kannur was
presented as an overpowered character
throughout the series so what I'm doing
in this video rather than just looking
at current strengths is counting down
the characters that were presented us
the most opie in the manga so far even
if the characters aren't as overpowered
anymore in the manga obviously I'm gonna
be presenting my opinion but if you
disagree or think I should have included
another overpowered character feel free
to let me know in the comments now
without further ado let's jump into it
first stop in 10th place we have zelgius
from the beginning back when the ten
commandments were introduced in chapter
109 cell just was singled out as someone
special near the end of the chapter we
see Mellie Otis trembling and sweating
clearly worried he says they're awake
and we jump to a shot of zeldron
suggesting that even among the
commandments he is definitely commandant
to worry about he is also the one
leading them and giving orders which
further suggests his great power way
later we get to see Zelda's original
power in action ominous nebulae and it
is insanely powerful but that's not all
he matches his original power which
makes him impervious to physical attacks
with the power he borrowed from the
demon king which makes him impervious to
all magic attacks Ludo Shah who is said
to have a combat class of 200 1000 at
this point is completely powerless
against ljus attack
it just keeps sucking him in and
damaging him not allowing him to get
anywhere close to zelgius although Eskin
or in the one motive and she overpowers
all just as the smile with sunshine and
finally the demon king takes his magic
resistance back the fact that zelgius
kept
tough battle after tough battle and
getting back up also speaks to his
strength his original power and the
magic resistance he borrowed from the
demon king make for one of the most Opie
combinations in the show and it wouldn't
have been beaten at that point if it
didn't happen to be noon or if Chandler
was quicker in blocking out the Sun in
ninth place we have Merlin you can bet
that any character called Merlin from a
series based on Arthurian legend will be
OPA F and she definitely is one of the
most popular ways to introduce an
overpowered character is to have them
show up and easily defeat another
character that was previously presented
as being overpowered and that is the way
Merlin is introduced Vivian was
introduced as the kingdom of Lyon is's
greatest mage the rest of the sins could
not keep up with her and her magic at
all that is until Merlin shows up before
even showing herself Merlin gets Vivian
to beg her to stop torturing her through
teleportation magic although Vivian is
the strongest mage in the kingdom Mel
Yodas introduces Merlin as Britannia
strongest mage we also find out that
Vivian was her pupil after
embarrassingly overpowering Vivian
Merlin goes on to simply erase Vivian's
perfect cube a spell that no one was
supposed to be able to break through
even if they combined their powers
Vivian says that Merlin is cheating and
she is so overpowered that it does feel
that way at times her original magic
infinity can stop time and keep a spell
going indefinitely unless she decides to
stop it she stopped her own aging pretty
much allowing her to live forever if
anything ever threatens her body she can
escape into her sacred treasure the
Morningstar all dan she knows more magic
spells than probably anyone in the show
she tricked the godlike figures the
demon king and the supreme deity the
demon king gave her detailed information
on all the secrets and mysteries of the
underworld and divine protection that
could defend against the brainwashing of
the goddesses and the supreme deity gave
her divine protection able to nullify
any and all manner of dark curses and
Commandments both wanted her to join
their side but she managed to take the
gifts from both and safely escaped
without joining either side despite the
fact that her highest recorded combat
class was 4700
and she was able to easily defeat
opponents with much higher combat
classes like grey road she even managed
to overpower Chandler and Cusack at the
same time who had a combined power level
of 341,000 unfortunately the memories of
esther osa being mile returned and
distracted merlin long enough for
Chandler and Cusack diffuse back into
the original demon who was too strong
for Merlin to deal with
even so Marella has proven time and time
again that she deserves to be called
overpowered in eighth place we got the
pinnacle of the human race the one who
stands atop all clans Lord ESCA nor can
I get a hashtag praise the sun in the
comment
ESCA noir was extremely Opie Rockabye
revealed in an interview back before he
revealed Marella and Eska north that the
other two sins had yet to show up
because they were strong he wanted to
save the more overpowered characters for
later thus suggesting that Eskin or who
he saved for last was the most
overpowered and he definitely was at the
time of his introduction while the seven
deadly sins had trouble keeping up with
the weakest of the Ten Commandments in
the beginning like GLE and Eska nor was
able to effortlessly defeat him in fact
he didn't have to do much ghal and the
commandment that was giving the other
sins serious trouble up to this point
without even using his critical over
mode lost the esken or because he got
scared
he wasn't just overpowered by askin or
he was so outmatched that he tried to
run away in fear and turn to stone
because of his own commandment then
mulaskey tries to eat eScan or soul and
it simply burns her from the inside s
Kannur for a long time goes from one
impressive victory to the next he easily
defeats Asura so one of the strongest
commandments who had previously managed
to defeat Mele Otis in his Diwan form
where he becomes the invincible
incarnation of power for one minute when
the Sun is at its peak he is able to
defeat Mele Otis in assault mode with
nothing more than the swipe of his hand
this is supposedly how strong melee Otis
was when he was the leader of the ten
commandments the version that all the
other Commandments feared and yet the
one is able to take him out of
commission with a swipe of his hand
later the one is able to stop soldiers
near invincible ominous nebula attack
with a karate chop he is about to finish
soldiers off but unfortunately for Eskin
or Chandler blocks out
Isana and eskimo revert back to his
weeknight time form nevertheless it is
important to remember that the one has
never been defeated in battle to date
for all these reasons s kannur no matter
what happens in the future deserves to
be remembered as one of the most Opie
characters ever next up in seventh place
we have the original demon the true form
of Cusack and Chandler as I mentioned
previously
Merlin despite how Opie she was accepted
the fact that she was no match for the
original demon when she saw him in fact
the first thing Merlin says when she
sees the original demon is that they've
lost all chance of victory although
we've been doing seven deadly sins
content for a long time on this channel
personally my first seven deadly sins
video was about the original demon when
I read that chapter I was so hyped that
I just had to do a video on him which
speaks to how well nook have I
introduced him into the story when you
get one of the most overpowered
characters in the show Merlin herself
saying that she's got no chance of
victory against an opponent not even a
1% chance but no chance you know that
that opponent is gonna be OPA F this
being is the original fusion of two of
the strongest demons in history and he
was so strong that he even tried to
rebel against the demon king at one
point he toys around with Eska noir and
is completely unimpressed with him not
only that the more damage he takes the
greater his power becomes because of his
original power crisis however as we know
Opie characters are constantly used to
establish the overpowered nests of
another character and eventually the
original demon serves to show how strong
mile has become after getting sunshine
back Miele finishes him off with one
attack but keep in mind the original
demons body was breaking down and
welcoming its imminent destruction the
whole time he was fighting despite being
used as a guinea pig to show off miles
knew slash old power the original demon
is one of my favourite antagonists in
the show and the way knockabout
presented his overpowered dismay'd those
chapters that featured him some of the
most hyped chapters in the entire series
in sixth place we have King with full
grown wings King was always an
impressive character even back when Mel
Yodas Diann and bond were strong to beat
gila king could easily overpower her he
was presented as Opie from the beginning
however after he gets his full-grown
wings he is on another level of
overpowered nacelle together the N King
and go third could do nothing against a
mile who had absorbed four commandments
even a combined attack from all three
proved fruitless mile is set to be over
a power level of 200 thousand at this
point yet after he gets his full-grown
wings
King effortlessly overpowers him not
only does King become the strongest
fairy King in history he also becomes
one of the strongest characters in the
series not only are all of his sacred
treasures different forms greatly
enhanced he can now use multiple spirit
spears at the same time we see him at
one point using as many as four spirit
spears at the same time as if this
wasn't impressive enough he is able to
go from this fight to almost finishing
off the original demon from a distance
with full-grown wings
King can fight which a staple from a
very large distance but this is not him
at full power the drawbacks are a he is
not used to fighting from a distance B
he can only use one spear spear from a
distance and C fighting from a distance
drains a lot of magic power very quickly
with all these drawbacks King is still
strong enough to almost finish off the
original demon he uses the spirit Spears
fourth form some fire to launch an Opie
solar beam at the original demon bud
zelgius steps in and cancels it out
using the power he borrowed from the
demon king he clearly felt the need to
step in suggesting that Kings attack
would have done serious damage to the
original demon then the fairy King
continues to overpower zelgius while he
fights him with one spirit spear from a
long distance King is no match for the
demon king when he shows up but it is
also important to note that at this
point he has run out of magic power
so he's far from being at his strongest
the truth is we've never seen King go
all-out against an opponent with a close
opponent and a full tank of magic King
has to be even more overpowered than
we've seen so far and that's saying a
lot because what we've seen so far has
already been very impressive next in
fifth place we have mild with sunshine
after mile gets sunshine he takes out
the original demon with one attack as if
that wasn't impressive enough he goes on
to stop cell justice Opie attack ominous
nebulae like Eska nor did accept mile
has an even easier time doing it instead
of needing to use a karate chop like the
one did miles proximity alone is enough
to stop the attack and meld souderses
sword keep in mind this is the same
sword that could block the ones karate
chop and stay intact and this isn't even
mile into one mode this is an afternoon
mile and he stilled this much stronger
than the one although he is no match for
the demon king as with Harlequin we
haven't seen him at his strongest we
know that ESCA nor is the one
drastically increased his power so it
makes sense that miles the one form
would drastically increase his own and
considering that he is already stronger
than Eskin ores the one before entering
that form we can barely imagine how Opie
mile can potentially become for that one
minute of the day when the Sun is at its
peak I really hope we get to see mile in
the one mode before the series finishes
it would no doubt be one of the most
overpowered moments in the series next
we have gone after purgatory while King
and mile couldn't make the demon king
break a sweat bond is able to surprise
him and wipe that smug smile off his
face bond has spent the equivalent of
over 1,000 years in purgatory
since one minute in the outside world is
about one year in purgatory I've
compared purgatory to a super extreme
hyperbolic time chamber not only is a
minute on the outside a year in
purgatory but the conditions in
purgatory are unbelievably harsh the
conditions would have killed bond if he
wasn't immortal his body was constantly
being burned frozen and poisoned but
eventually it adjusted to the harsh
conditions of purgatory thus by the time
he returned to the human realm
his body was way stronger and it's
tolerance had greatly increased before
using stache to borrow about half of
gallons power left him a mobile but
after he has increased his body's
tolerance so much he can probably steal
a huge amount of power from a strong
opponent and use it to fight for an
extended period of time
Merlin king with full-grown wings and
mile with sunshine all Opie characters
could do nothing as a demon king and yet
bond as they noticed was able to go
blow-for-blow with him he is able to
keep up with a character that was
presented as a god in the
which is just insane especially when you
consider that bond was one of the weaker
characters in the series for a long time
before he returned from purgatory and
got his huge power boost ironically
although he's given away his immortality
bond is currently more opie than he's
ever been
next we have a tie between second and
third place it's a tie between the demon
king and the supreme deity I will talk
more about the demon king since we've
seen him in action more than we've seen
the supreme deity in action
however the supreme deity is always
presented as being equal to the demon
king in power neither one was strong
enough to overpower the other during the
holy war so it's only fair that I put
the supreme deity this high up on the
list the demon king and supreme deity
were strong enough to completely destroy
the city of beli Alwyn and curse smelly
Otis and Elizabeth they were able to
overcome the rules of life and death
when they cursed Elizabeth with endless
reincarnation and Mellie Otis with his
own version of immortality
according to Mellie Otis both he and
Elizabeth could do nothing in the face
of their gods and their overwhelming
power both the demon king and supreme
deity were so strong that they each
split their power the demon king split
his power in the form of the ten
commandments and the supreme deity split
her power in the form of four Grace's
that she gave to the four Archangels
think about how strong sunshine makes
esken or and mile and then think about
the fact that that's only one part of
her own true power if that's not
overpowered I don't know what is and as
we've seen with the demon king he has so
far been able to take on all of the
characters previously mentioned in this
list and that's before he's even
reconnected with the body he's left in
purgatory which might well contain much
more of his power even in an imperfect
form with Mellie Otis battling him on
the inside he is able to take on bonds
all dressed and all of the other Opie
individuals present for an extended
period of time and seemingly maintained
the upper hand however as we've seen in
Chapter 305 actor Mellie Otis beats him
on the inside the combined power of the
sins is enough to stop the weakened
demon king and bring Mellie Otis back
the demon Kings ability the ruler is
also Opie any attacks and weakening
maneuvers made against him turn into
healing and strengthening ones instead
this ability makes him near invents
but Bob's new ability to give power
which ends up hurting the demon king
instead forces him to deactivate this
ability in purgatory
the demon king also spent the equivalent
of over 1.5 billion years in purgatory
and he was already older when he entered
so you can bet he's lived a long life
even though the average lifespan of a
demon is about 1,000 years it is
possible they use some power similar to
the one he used on Mellie Otis to ensure
his own immortality
since he's definitely lived a lot longer
than any other demon we know of he can
clearly take over other people's bodies
as well like Mellie Otis's youthful body
so chances are like Merlyn he could just
go on living forever it is also possible
that we have yet to see the demon Kings
full power which we might see if his Ten
Commandments reconnect with his real
body in purgatory at the same time we
have reason to believe that the supreme
deity has just as many impressive
abilities and powers that could match
that of the demon king however there is
one character who has recently revealed
himself to be even more Opie before we
get to the most Opie character in the
seven deadly sins I just wanted to give
a quick shout out to two O P characters
whose overpowered nasai I today the
seven deadly sins movie prisoners of the
sky this opie list is going off of what
we've seen in the main manga series so
far but it is worth mentioning that the
Endura baroja and hawks mom proved to be
very Opie in the prisoners of the sky
film it took the combined efforts of the
seven deadly sins and the Celestials to
defeat the Endura and Hawks mom was
revealed to be the mother of chaos and
not only tackles the Endora but also
absorbs one of his massive attacks and
sends it flying back apparently Hawks
mom possesses so much darkness that she
was feared by the demon clan and so much
light that she was revered by the
goddess clan definitely sounds like an
Opie character but we haven't seen
enough of her in action in the main
story to officially put her on this list
so I just wanted to give her the
honorary mention she clearly deserves
now then off to the number one most Opie
character in the seven deadly sins
Mellie Otis that's right the man who at
one point could do nothing against the
demon king and the supreme deity but
Allah has changed since then Mellie Otis
has awakened his original power that
seems to be tied to him being the
or the source of destruction as a demon
king put it not only has malleolus been
able to stand up to the demon king since
he's awakened his true power he has been
able to absolutely wreck him during each
encounter in purgatory he took off the
demon King's entire arm using his power
and the demon king couldn't do anything
to stop him all he could do was panic
and scream after him inside meliodas his
body belly Otis's emotions easily
overpowered the demon king it seems that
he's combined his insane original power
with Kings condensed power and that's
allowed him to destroy the demon King's
sword and body like it was nothing the
demon king once presented as a god seems
completely powerless against malli otis
who may even go on to absorb the power
of the ten commandments since they were
in his body already this would add even
more power to his already insane power
love he is so powerful now that the
demon king says he will only be able to
stay in the mortal plane for about a day
I have plenty of videos you can check
out on this channel that break down
exactly how Opie Melly Otis is but for
the purposes of this video I think you
get the point he has been able to
completely overpower a character that
was previously presented as a God and he
was able to do it multiple times and
relatively easily I truly can't see
anyone else putting up a serious fight
against Melly Otis at this point he is
just too overpowered and that is it for
today's video thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video make
sure to smash that like one to let me
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and ring that notification bell so you
don't miss any new 7 Deadly Sins videos
for daily 7 Deadly Sins content make
sure to follow us on instagram at anime
uproar thank you as always to our
patrons especially to our pro tier
patrons keelon and gilgamesh and toward
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
atop all clans lil lady KD Maddie Mac
and ace thank you so much if you want to
support more content like this you can
do so for as little as $1 a month and
then your name will appear in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here you will also get access to
the patron only VIP discord so
definitely consider supporting our
content over on patreon thanks again and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]